[Music]
here with Russell Westbrook Russ man can
you tell me about the keys to winning
tonight um grinding it out man U it's
ups and down start the game but I
thought adversity we stuck together I
did a great job of playing together
defensively closing out the game the
right way so have we got this win get
ready to go on the road and Russ
yourself again another efficient night
pushing the ball being relentless Russ
it was something you told me you talking
about defense last week you told explain
let everybody know what that means first
team I've been uh really locked in
defensively a garden every single night
and like I said like I told you last
time there not many times I get scored
on I'm taking pride in that and making
sure I'm coming in and setting the tone
for my team defensively so I'm going to
keep doing that every single night Russ
I want to set you up for that man what
you think about the groove that you got
your copers in right now just tell me
what what is the ceiling for this team
man I think uh for us man we taking day
by day I know we got so much talent in
this room uh we got so many great hall
of famers in this locker room and our
job is to make sure that every night we
keep chipping away chipping away at the
ultimate goal and that's the
championship Russ I'm disappointed man
you didn't congratulate me
man You' been here a long time that's
why I congratulate you on uh the 40th
season You' been here I ain't that no
Russ congratulations thank you brother
back to inside joke from the last game
Russ he's a
man